President Trump announced today his
endorsement of the first-step Act a
criminal justice reform bill with
bipartisan support ironically just as
creepy porn lawyer Michael avenatti you
know the male feminist is arrested for
beating a woman we will analyze the case
for and against letting criminals like
avenatti allegedly off the hook then
Michelle Obama keeps gaslighting flake
keeps flaking and Nancy Pelosi possibly
loses control of her own party
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
we've got our first bipartisan agreement
in a very long time which is how you
know we should oppose it and whatever it
is if you've got Republicans and
Democrats agreeing on something it's
probably no good we will get to the
first step act and break it down but
first let's make a little money with
purple mattress so you see you're here
in my boudoir on the road in my hotel
room that mattress back there that's not
a purple mattress that's why I look
under slept I don't feel as good as I
usually do purple mattress is
unbelievable I am proselytizing for
purple mattress it is so good it's not
an innerspring it's not exactly a memory
foam it's this brand-new material it
sleeps both cool it's well it sleeps
very cool and but it's also both firm
and soft somehow it's both of those
things it is unbelievable I love it it
is a tremendous product it was developed
by a rocket scientist it's unlike any
mattress that you've ever slept on
highly recommended right now you can
take advantage of the hundred night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return that for a full
refund backed by a 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns free in-home setup
and old mattress removal you will love
purple you will not return it I'm
telling you I got back problems I got
back problems in my family I have never
slept better go right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress a free purple
pillow those are expensive pillows and
they're very very nice that's in
addition to all the other great free
gifts are offering site-wide just text
cough fa ce o-- v f EF e - 47 47 47 that
is the only way to get this free pillow
text Kofi pay CoV feef e - 47 47 47 COV
fe fe - 47 47 47 do that right now do
that while you're listening to me
explain the first step back to you so
this is a big moment president Trump
just endorsed the first step act he had
Democrats and Republicans behind him
here is president Trump explaining these
members have reached a bipartisan
agreement did I hear the word bipartisan
did I hear can I hear that word that's a
nice word bipartisan agreement on prison
reform legislation known as the first
step and that's what it is it's a first
step but it's a very big first step
today I'm thrilled to announce my
support for this bipartisan bill that
will make our community safer and give
former inmates a second chance at life
after they have served their time okay
so I do I do like that he opens up he's
joking about bipartisan this actually
does help him in the sense that the left
is trying to portray him as this very
partisan very extreme figure when really
he is willing to work with Democrats I
think he's actually eager to they're
just too foolish to take him up on the
offer but what is this act the act is
called the first-step Act it is the
formerly incarcerated reenter society
transformed safely transitioning every
person Act because congressman love
stupid acronyms that's why formerly
incarcerated society transforms say okay
blahblahblah really what it is is
rehabilitation programs for early
release for criminals that's the whole
thing the left is denying this the left
is denying that this is all just about
early release for criminals but that's
what it is
voxcom said the bill would not reform or
reduce how long people are sentenced to
prison for which has been the prime
target of criminal justice reform errs
over the past few years instead the bill
focuses on rehabilitating people once
they're already in prison by
incentivizing them with the possibility
of earlier release to partake in
rehabilitation programs that's it's not
quite a contradiction that they've just
made but it might as well be you're
saying oh it doesn't really reduce how
long people are sentenced for it just
reduces how long they're in prison for
okay that is a real distinction it's a
real distinction in so much as there's
front-end prison reform and there's
back-end prison reform the front-end is
it decides how long people are going to
get a sentence for and then the back end
is how long they actually stay there but
the effect is the exactly the same which
is criminals getting out of prison early
that said some conservatives are for it
obviously President Trump the Heritage
Foundation Heritage Foundation fellow
John Michael Seidler is for it he gave a
long explanation made a conservative
case for it so did Mike Lee I love Mike
Lee I like a lot of these things Donald
Trump the Heritage Foundation Mike Lee
but I'm still very skeptical Mike Lee
opens up his piece defending it today
and he refers to common-sense sentencing
reform whenever I hear somebody talk
about common sense
blah blah blah legislation I run away
because it never seems to be common
sense they say common sense I think they
protest too much it's one of those
mealy-mouthed words that the right and
the left both use but it makes me
skeptical and then Mike Lee in his piece
goes on he tells the story of a young
father of two who got caught by an
informant selling pot he sold three dime
bags of pot to an informant while he was
in possession of a gun he got a 55 year
sentence notice how they try to bury
certain things in here so it's it's a
young father of two okay that's fine um
he he happened to be in possession of a
gun but he wasn't II didn't shoot the
gun he didn't grab the gun okay that's
fine because we all would agree that
passing out three dime bags of pot is
not worth spending most of your life in
jail we I think we can all agree with
that
in Los Angeles there are billboards now
for marijuana delivery services so it's
legal in many states but it's still
illegal as a federal matter so we would
all agree with that however one if
you're the father of two don't sell
drugs don't be a drug dealer just my
first guess at two if you're the father
of two who's selling drugs to make his
money don't carry a gun that sounds
pretty stupid don't do that either
that said still maybe you shouldn't go
to jail for 55 years
fine by me reform that law reform the
mandatory minimum for selling three dime
bags of pot at the federal level fine by
me
that no issue but that's not really what
the first-step Act is about one of the
issues he brings up that it's a father
of two I think because one of the real
issues with imprisoning people is it can
wreak havoc on families obviously if
you're in prison for 50 years you can't
raise your kids you can't be with your
wife a lot of conservative walks have
pointed out
that each year behind bar increases the
likelihood of divorce by 32% so every
single year that you're incarcerated
your chance of divorcing your spouse
goes up by 32% eventually you're almost
certainly going to get divorced okay
that's not a good statistic we're
pro-family as conservatives we don't
want that however what they forget to
tell you is that very few inmates are
married so even even in 2002 which was
the closest study I could find on this
only 16% of inmates were married and I
can only imagine that that that number
has decreased in the last 16 years and a
lot of evidence suggests that it is so
the better point I think that
conservatives could make if they want to
support the first-step Act is
specifically on black families because
black men account for 6 percent of the
country they account for 38 percent of
prison inmates that's true in at the
state level that's true at the federal
level so obviously is it hugely
disproportionate number of black men
committing crime and then being
sentenced to prison for crime
this obviously reduces the availability
of those men for marriage and it's been
suggested in some quarters that this has
caused the breakup of the black family
there are other causes of that too but
marriages declined immensely among black
Americans from the 1960s to the present
the rates of marriage in the 1960s for
blacks was 61% today it's 38 per I'm
sorry today it's 32% so it's it's almost
cut in half now what are some causes of
that maybe prison maybe welfare as
Daniel Patrick Moynihan suggested maybe
the the reason I think it's probably
much more cultural and is much more to
do with government programs like welfare
dependency which incentivizes breaking
up the family is that there's been a
major marriage decline among white
people too so among whites marriages
declined from 74 percent to 56 percent
during that exact time not as greatly as
the black family has been broken up but
still a pretty huge chunk one of the
major Republicans campaigning against
the first-step Act is Tom cotton
excellent Congressman Tom cotton is now
apparently this is all just being
reported by various sources has been
lobbying various law enforcement
to drop their support of the measure
apparently it was his campaigning that
was responsible for the law enforcement
association or I'm sorry the federal law
Enforcement Officers Association from
dropping their endorsement for it and
what Tom cotton says he goes out pretty
boldly and I 100% agree with him on this
the problem in America is not over
incarceration you hear this from the
left you heard from libertarians you
hear it from conservatives they say oh
the problem we over incarcerate there
are too many inmates in our prisons no
the problem in America is under
incarceration we don't catch enough of
our criminals law enforcement in this
country identifies 19 percent of the
perpetrators of property crime
eighty-one percent of people who
perpetrate property crime just walk free
there they are never even identified
this is maybe lucky for them it's very
merciful to the criminals but for the
people who have their property destroyed
or stolen it's not merciful at all
they're being wronged and that's
injustice
how about violent crime in law
enforcement identifies only 40 percent
of violent criminals in America so fewer
than 50 percent of violent criminals get
identified and are even brought up for
criminal justice in the first place 53
percent get away that is way way too
much so what are some good things about
this bill I would say the good thing
about it is that it's not terribly
extensive it it's you know it still
keeps people in prison for a while Jared
Kushner identifies why each conservative
supporting this is wrongheaded Jared
Kushner said quote the biggest thing we
want to do is really define what the
purpose of a prison is is the purpose to
punish as the purpose to warehouse or is
the purpose to rehabilitate we will get
to that in a second first let's make a
little money because taking care of your
health is a commitment and that can feel
overwhelming that's why I have been
loving Omax three ultra-pure supplements
because with mx3 you just need to do one
little thing to experience big health
benefits you don't even have to think
about it listen sometimes I don't sleep
that much I'm a little tired my memory
goes there are incredible
of benefits right now go to try Oh max
calm slash cough FAC o VF EF e today
you'll get a box of Oh max three
ultra-pure for free with your first
purchase that is try Oh max dot-com
slash cough FA a a trial max calm slash
cough f8 is the purest omega-3
supplement on the planet contains nearly
94% high quality omega-3s
its optimal health made easy so there
look omega threes are amazing at
alleviating joint pain inflammation
muscle soreness they make you feel your
best they make you feel your best
post-workout and especially if you're on
the road you know you're not sleeping
very well you're a little foggy headed
it's really good it make you feel a lot
better it can improve mood focus memory
boost cardiovascular and brain health
plus oh so much more it just makes sense
to try omega-3 supplements so what does
that address do you remember try Oh max
calm / co' f fa c OV e fa fa get a box
of o max 3 ultra pure for free with your
first purchase
try o max calm / go f f/a to get your
free box of o max 3 with your first
purchase
what is it try on max calm / golf fa
terms and conditions apply because they
always do in this life so Jared Kushner
is saying about criminal justice reform
apparently he's one of the big people
pushing this in the White House he's
saying what is the purpose is the
purpose of prison to punish or is it to
rehabilitate and I think jared is very
smart I think he's a very capable guy
and he is falling into a classic
misunderstanding the purpose of criminal
justice is justice it is to punish
people who have committed crimes if the
purpose is not to punish them then
there's no reason to have them there in
the first place if the purpose is just
to rehabilitate then how come we only do
it against criminals why there are
plenty of people who need a lot of
rehabilitation I could probably use a
little rehabilitation in my life why why
is it that we only apply it to criminals
we only apply it to criminals because
the primary purpose of criminal justice
is to punish criminals it is retribution
for crimes so I totally understand how
if you lose sight of that if you lose
sight of the value of punishing
criminals you would absolutely be for
all of
let the prisoners out put them into
lovely little daycare facilities where
they can learn to be nice and sing
Kumbaya that's fine
but as Adam Smith pointed out mercy to
the guilty is cruelty to the innocent
this certainly applies at the level of
our government and of a criminal justice
system and by the way the more that you
introduce these kind of programs which
give preferential treatment to some
people who tried out not other people
and at one level but not another level
you are increasing the injustice
so to Mike Lee's point if some poor guy
he was selling drugs when he shouldn't
have been he had a gun maybe you
shouldn't have had a gun on him maybe he
shouldn't go to jail for 55 years
because of that that's fine if you want
to reduce it to ten years or five years
or or I don't know three years do
whatever you want or you want to
legalize pot again that's fine if you
want to vote on it make that a law but
to as a matter for federal inmates give
them this ticket out of jail it seems
crazy the other good thing about this is
it only effects federal inmates and the
majority of inmates are in state prisons
but still we should not let this creep
into our conservative conversation too
much because it is totally missing sight
of the purpose of prison speaking of
people who might go to prison Michael
avenatti I don't know if you've seen
this today kind of a sad story it's an i
it's ironic so there's a little
schadenfreude for the creepy porn where
he's been arrested for beating a woman
obviously feel horrible for the woman if
these allegations are true
that's a terrible thing the only good
thing out of it is that Michael avenatti
is getting what's his because Michael
avenatti this guy has shamelessly
portrayed himself as a women's advocate
he says a women's advocate his whole
life what did I tell you what did I tell
you about male feminists I just gave a
speech on this the other night in how to
be a man when you look like a Maddow
male feminists are the creepiest people
on the face of the earth if a male
feminist comes walking around your
daughter run in the other directions
take pick them up throw them into the
next town do not let him around your
daughter they're very creepy how many uh
how many feminists gallons did Harvey
Weinstein go to I think a lot how many
how many feminist galas was he smiling
with Meryl Streep and Oprah Winfrey
I think a lot he's still a big creep and
we know a vanadis a creep but now he
might beat women as well avenatti for
his part is vehemently denying charges
here he is first of all I want to thank
the hard-working men and women of the
LAPD for their professionalism in their
work today they had no option in light
of the allegations secondly I have never
struck a woman I never will strike a
woman I have been an advocate for
women's rights my entire career and I'm
going to continue to be an advocate I am
NOT going to be intimidated from
stopping what I am doing I am a father
to two beautiful smart daughters I would
never disrespect them by touching a
woman inappropriately or striking a
woman I am looking forward to a full
investigation at which point I am
confident that I will be fully
exonerated I also want to thank everyone
for their support that is reached out
you know my character you know me as a
man and I appreciate it thank you my
character Oh Michael a vanadis character
what is everybody knows Michael a
vanadis character don't they he's a
creepy porn lawyer that's his character
who exploits women to try to advance his
own would-be political career which is
just going up in flames
stormy Daniel says she might find a new
lawyer she says if the charges are true
she's gonna dump him and find a new
lawyer not even good enough for stormy
Daniels Michael avenatti character we
know his character is that he dug up a
bunch of fake accusers also to propel
his own political career for which he is
by the way being criminally investigated
now that's great he said he also won't
be intimidated
do you realize what he's saying by that
when he says I won't be intimidated what
he is implying is that this is a false
charge now I don't know how how good
your memory is a few weeks ago Michael
avenatti was leading the chorus of
saying we need to believe all women
we need to believe Julie sweating it we
need to believe known liars because
women can't lie women never lie
so is believe all women until they
accused Michael avenatti ha ha ha ha ha
what a jerk so what are the charges
TMZ this is according to TMZ a woman
filed a felony domestic violence report
concerning Michael avenatti she showed
up with a face quote swollen and bruised
with red marks on both cheeks this
incident allegedly occurred on Tuesday
but the confrontation that everybody's
talking about was on Wednesday this was
when a woman was on a sidewalk with her
cellphone with sunglasses on to cover
her face because she'd apparently been
beaten she was sobbing and screaming
into the phone quote I can't believe you
did this to me I'm going to get a
restraining order against you this is
when all of a sudden Michael avenatti
bursts into the scene and avenatti shows
up yelling she hit me first and then he
added this is BS this is effing BS this
is when she hit me first that was his
excuse we'll go into the legitimacy of
that excuses just a second but first
let's think a new sponsor that we have
brownells o brownells now we're talking
about a company that supports the Second
Amendment that has for 80 years when
when they called he said hey Michael we
are one of the biggest gun marketplaces
out there you got all your guns you can
get your accessories and get your ammo
you can get all this do you think that
your listeners would like that so you
know I think I have a feeling they would
like that very much
it is super cool it is the world's
leading supplier of firearms ammunition
firearm accessories I love them they
offer an industry exclusive guaranteed
forever warranty on all parts and
accessories they offer nearly 120
thousand items I've been like a kid in a
candy store deciding what I want from
new guns and ammo to nearly any gun part
imaginable if more than 550 500 partner
FFL around the country to make your
online gun purchase go very smoothly its
family-owned its veteran owned doing
business in the country's heartland of
Iowa for 80 years they've been
supporting law enforcement agencies and
charities and military charities also
for 80 years
here's where
it's fun throughout the month of
November Brownells is working to help
veterans in a big way Brownells hashtag
Operation 100k event is soliciting
donations from customers and will match
every donor dollar up to a hundred grand
donations will be divided between three
well-respected military charities
Special Operations Wounded Warriors
mission 22 folds of Honor you can donate
by adding money to your purchase from
brownells.com or by visiting
brownells.com slash operation 100,000
and donating directly a visit right now
brownells.com today pick up some gun
gear and help out with a fabulous great
cause so this is Michael a vanadis
excuse apparently well we don't know
exactly what happened but according to
witnesses he storms in where the woman
is and he says she hit me first this is
BS this is effing BS but just some
advice I know he went to law school I
never went to law school but a little
bit of advice don't start justifying the
action that you then deny that you did
that's a bad idea when you start
explaining why you hit her and then deny
that you hit her that doesn't look good
just come and say I didn't do anything
if you say she hit me first it's like
little kids it's actually like little
kids reason why'd you hit your brother
he hit me first you shouldn't hit him no
I didn't hit him he just said he had you
for of course now of course Michael
avenatti is already being investigated
crit he was turned over for criminal
investigation by the Senate Judiciary
Committee for all of those fake
Cavanaugh allegations he came up some
are saying that his political career is
falling apart I mentioned that earlier
that's the talk it's in it's on fire I
think this guarantee is he's gonna be
the 20/20 nominee isn't it done if you
are gonna be the Democrat nominee for
president
don't you basically have to be under
criminal investigation at this point
don't you have to be just a dirty rotten
crooked criminal ayah this is really
gonna help him unless Hillary gets in
the race again then it's gonna be a
head-to-head to see who can be the most
disreputable presidential candidate in
history speaking of people who want to
run for the presidency Michelle Obama is
back in action
it's unclear if Michelle Obama wants to
be the president or if she wants to be
Oprah
Maureen Callahan had a great piece in
the New York Post today that said she
was either going to become president or
a self-help guru that's what all of this
becoming is about becoming it's all that
kind of pseudo spiritual Oprah II stuff
in either case she's making the this
book tour go around and she keeps
putting her foot in her mouth here's
Michelle Obama tax payers are paying for
that and the truth is yes you know you
don't pay rent and you don't pay for
staff but every thing every dish every
they they would count the number of
peanuts that you eat and charge it back
no so you'd get a bill at the end of it
it's not a you know it's not at all we
live in a White House y'all I mean this
is not a complaint it's just something
that people don't understand okay so she
is saying she's not complaining right
she's not complaining about it but she
obviously is she is she said I'm just
explaining this to everybody the reason
that people don't know about this is
because we've never ever heard a first
lady complain about this before that the
president and the first lady have to pay
for their own meals that they don't just
get that for free this is the first time
we've ever heard this I suppose she's
better than Hillary Clinton though
because the reason that we might be able
to infer that the president the first
lady have to pay for certain things is
that when the Clintons left the White
House they stole the furniture they
literally packed up furniture on the
moving truck and took it with them they
had to give it back because it was theft
you're not allowed to take everything
but the thing that's really I mean there
was a silly comment from Michelle Obama
but she's selling these tickets for
thousands of dollars a seat so she's got
to give a little juice and she's got to
give away okay fine that's whatever when
she came on later she said in this
conversation quote I'm finally claiming
my story is the quintessential American
story
yes I'm black yes I'm a woman and yes I
grew up working class and my parents
didn't get to go to college or finish
college how dare someone tell me I don't
love my country the first part of what
she said he is
true she I don't know why she's finally
claiming it I wish she had claimed it
earlier it is true her story is a
quintessential American story
she's a black woman she grew up
working-class her parents didn't get to
finish college and she became the First
Lady of the United States she went to
law school she was a lawyer she became
the first lady it's hard to imagine
succeeding at a higher level than that
however she finishes that she says how
dare someone tell me I don't love my
country the reason why we've suggested
that Michelle Obama doesn't love her
country is because she told us herself
here's Michelle Obama in 2008 but what
we've learned over this year is that
hope is making a comeback it is making a
comeback and let me tell you something
for the first time in my adult lifetime
I'm proud of my country and not just
because Barack is done well but because
I think people are hungry for change
first time in my adult life I've been
proud of my country she says it and then
she has the audacity to go out and say
how dare you suggest that I don't love
my country we're suggesting it because
you say it's this constant gaslighting
it actually reminds me do you remember
that time that Ben Shapiro was on Piers
Morgan and he he's they were debating
gun control and piers tried to use this
tactic to to deflect from something he'd
done he said how dare you here's the
clip what you tend to do is you tend to
demonize people who differ from you
politically by standing on the graves of
the children of Sandy Hook saying they
don't seem to care enough about the dead
kids if they cared more about the dead
kids they would agree with you on policy
I think we can have a rational political
conversation about balancing rights and
risks and rewards of all of these
different policies but I don't think
that what we need to do is demonize
people on the other side as as being
unfeeling about that about what happened
in there you accuse me of standing on
the grace I've seen you do it repeatedly
piers like I say how dare you I mean you
can keep saying that but you've done it
repeatedly how dare you how dare you the
election of my husband is the first time
in my adult life I've ever been proud of
my country well piers you said that
that's the first time in your adult life
you've been proud of your country how
dare
you how dare you suggest that I said
what I said how day I saw you saying
this is one of the things that's so
frustrating about Michelle Obama if she
would have just apologized we would have
forgiven her she would have just said
wow that was a terrible statement I'm
sorry I it isn't true
I spoke out of I don't know I mean it's
actually a hard statement to explain
it's such a specific statement that
she's never been proud of her country
but if she said you know I have been
consumed in this ideological anger
against America and I realize now I'm
one of the luckiest people in the
history of the world and only in this
country could that ever happen what a
terrific country this is and I'm really
really sorry
I might have meant it when I said it but
I've realized how stupid and awful that
statement was if she had said that we
would have forgiven her but she has him
she's just denying that she ever said it
absolutely outrageous we have a lot more
to get to that we're not going to
because I want to get to mailbag today
so just remember if right now you are
out in Michigan I'm still in Michigan
come on out to the University of
Michigan tonight at 7:00 p.m. for the
latest stop on my Yap khofifah and
campus tour
it'll be very cold but those sweet sweet
leftist tears will be fresh and they'll
actually be snow they will be the
snowflakes the leftist tears we have
become the snowflakes so don't miss it
if you're on Daley wire comm thank you
very much you keep the lights on you
keep coffe fa that is typically in my
tumblr now it's in my nondescript water
bottle as I left my tumbler back in LA
don't be a fool like me get your tumbler
all the time because if you subscribe
you get me you get the under Clavin sure
you get the Ben Shapiro show it test
questions the mailbag who cares you get
the left is tears tumblr that's what
matters because what's really nice you
can have a hot or cold so if you catch
all those little leftist snowflakes
they'll stay cold they'll stay really
fresh and unique and beautiful go to
daily wire comm we got the mailbag
coming up we'll be right back
we got a lot today we have a lot to get
through from Elliot
dear professor cough effing with one of
the most pro America and assimilation
based immigration administration's we've
had in ages do you think there is any
chance that English will be made the
official language of the country rather
than just leaving it to the states I
hope so
I sure hope they do English should and
must become the official language of the
United States I have nothing against
other languages I rather like other
languages I speak other languages and I
encourage you to learn other languages
too however the left has brought us to
the place where we must have an official
language because we have so little that
unites us anymore in the country because
of the multiculturalism of the left
because the left insists on not
assimilating anybody into the American
culture on denigrating American culture
we have very little that unites us
including our language I mean it's a
sort of old stodgy complaint to hear
somebody angered by the phrase press 1
for English but it is an outrage that I
have to press 1 for English we are in
America if you had a little thing that
said you know press 1 for Spanish maybe
if at the end or hidden say okay that's
fine not there are a lot of people in
this country who don't speak English but
they should they should learn it they
should be made to learn it they should
ideally learn it before they get here
but if they don't do that they should
learn it immediately upon getting here
you know half of Michener half of my
family rather came on the Mayflower the
other half came on a sardine boat for
all intents and purposes they came over
from Italy and they took great pains to
learn English they refused even to speak
Italian in the household because they
wanted to become Americans and people in
this country who have come from other
places Central America or South America
should behave in exactly the same way
and they shouldn't speak Spanish in the
home or they shouldn't speak it very
much they should learn English this is
true of immigrants from East Asia this
is true of immigrants from all over the
place learn English because if we still
had a common culture that United us we
can't even agree on the American flag
anymore we can't even half the countries
protesting the flag at this point but if
we had a common culture a calm
entertainment culture common religious
culture common broadly broad values
culture that would be one thing but we
don't so we at least need to be united
by that I hope we get it through I'm
skeptical that we will I don't I think
that's probably a bridge too far
maybe they'll build the wall first but I
really hope that they do from Mario hi
Michael
wanted to ask your thoughts and insights
regarding the early church and the
raging debate then of the nature of
Jesus Christ
eventually the church decided on the
Holy Trinity however I also think some
of the other ideas are interesting and
perhaps equally valid can you discuss
your views so what Mario is talking
about is that in the early days of
Christianity there were heresies that
cropped up rather quickly within a
century or two centuries and they had
various perspectives on the nature of
God and the nature of Jesus and the
nature of the holy spirit they might be
interesting ideas they can't be equally
valid the reason that can't be equally
valid is they're contradictory ideas if
one idea says that Christ is God and the
other idea says that Christ is not God
then they can't be equally valid he
either is God or he is not God the
reason that I believe in the Trinity is
because I see it throughout Scripture
John 1 says in the beginning was the
word the logos Christ and the Word was
with God and the Word was God so we know
that Christ is God Christ says that he
is God at various points in the
scripture we know that the Holy Spirit
is God as well st. Paul writes in first
Corinthians quote the spirit teaches
everything even the depths of God for
what person knows a man's thoughts
except the spirit of the man which is in
him so also no one comprehends the
thoughts of God except the Spirit of God
so we now know that God is God God the
Father is God God the Son Christ is God
in God the Spirit the Holy Spirit is God
all three of these are God yet in the
early church there was some disagreement
about this there were various heresies
Arianism that's the heresy of arias who
very famously got punched in the face by
Santa Claus at the Council of Nicaea
arianism that heresy denied the divinity
of Christ there is another very early
Hera sequel
Marcion ism Marcin ISM embraced the god
of the New Testament but detested the
God of the Old Testament and rejected
the God of the Old Testament is somehow
different
there's Alba Jen Zionism which came
centuries later this was a Manichaean
duelist heresy that that despised the
material world there are a lot of
heresies and there are many many more
heresies than that my main conclusion
from all of this and I advise you to
take this under consideration as well is
that the Church Fathers
were extraordinarily smart spiritual
people and they got it right
the pea all of those various councils
the councils that came up with the
Nicene Creed speaking of the Council of
Nicaea or the councils that compiled the
Bible they really got it right they knew
what to put in and what to leave out
these are the smartest men in history
and they weren't bumbling idiots we from
our modernist perspective I think look
down on them as old people who you know
were various robes and didn't have
iPhones so they couldn't have been smart
these were extremely intelligent wise
people and they got it right and they've
got to write about the Trinity - from
amber hello mr. Noles I was listening to
Maxine Waters talking about most likely
becoming the head of House Financial
Services Committee and proud that she's
the first black woman to do so if the
left states that gender is fluid a
choice then why all of the celebrating
of the first openly lgbtq+ woman in
Congress the first Muslim woman in
Congress the youngest female in Congress
etc you make an excellent point doesn't
make a whole lot of sense this is why
transgenderism and and identity politics
more broadly has destroyed feminism
because you can have transgenderism or
you can have feminism but you can't have
both either gender and sex is innate
it's essential it defines our identity
it you can metaphysically be one well
not physically being the other if it's
so important that you will mutilate
yourself to more closely resemble the
other gender or everything's the same or
everything's exactly the same and gender
doesn't matter at all
either it matters intensely and in that
case either it's natural it can't be
changed or it can be changed it doesn't
matter at all it's not natural these
ideologies eat each other up at which is
why it's pretty funny I think if I ever
if I am ever elected to Congress I'm
going to identify as the the first black
gay Muslim leader of the Financial
Services Committee in fact I might even
identify that way now because why not
why am I not how who are you to tell me
who the heck are you to tell me that I'm
not the head of the House Financial
Services Committee check your priveledge
okay amber all right from Aaron Michael
how can I get a liberal girl talking
about her values in a non politically
charged way it's been my experience that
when people don't know they are talking
about politics they proclaim different
values than they would if they were
addressing a specific issue believing in
individual rights for instance thanks a
lot that's a very good point people very
often do not preach what they in fact
practice the first thing you got to do
is charm her this is good advice
generally when talking to women you know
be attractive be charming don't come at
it like you're gonna have a political
debate or something you want to hear
from her you want to get her ideas you
want and kind of maybe hit her from
don't literally don't be Michael
avenatti don't literally hit her but hit
her rhetorically from different angles
where she might not be as familiar and
asked simple but pointed questions I
actually think specificity here is
pretty helpful you could talk don't talk
about something that is you know so in
the news Donald Trump is tweeting about
it for instance but you could ask pretty
pointed questions about I don't know you
see a cute little baby on a stroller say
wow gosh isn't that baby so cute oh my
god look at that cute little baby oh my
goodness gracious
how oh my he's only two months old Wow
oh my just think two and a half months
ago he was inside you Wow look at that
look a and you could skin you could
murder it
I mean don't end it on that but point in
the direction of the logical conclusions
and the logical extremes of arguments
and if you do it in a way that is
conversation
not combative not debating then it might
just start turning some gears in the old
noggin and you don't even need to a
heart Bunny you don't need to resolve an
issue they're just plant the seeds this
is true by the way not just of talking
to girls was true of talking to people
generally and ultimately over time
people might come to that conclusion
it's very hard to convince somebody that
he's wrong it's very hard to leave a
discussion or a debate when someone will
actually say okay well at the end of
that debate I'm wrong and you're right
happens sometimes happens but not always
what it usually happens is they'll leave
they'll say I got to think about that
and then six months later they'll pass
off your opinion as their own which is
fine at least they got to the right
opinion from Matthew yo Mikey yo Matty
what's up what do you think of a maximum
wage end or maximum capital and property
ownership I have a sibling who keeps
proposing the billionaires shouldn't
legally be allowed to exist
terrible idea what do you think I love
billionaires
I love billionaires I've known a handful
of billionaires just threw my
meanderings in politics
they're wonderful billionaires have
always been very good to me I've never
gotten a job from a poor person I I
gotta tell ya billionaires have been a
lot better to me professionally then
poor people have nothing against poor
people they've just never given me a job
if they ever given you a job if they
ever given your brother a job I don't
think so why doesn't he like
billionaires they employ you
they don't take money away from you they
they just make more money on their own
product productive work doesn't take
money again away from someone else it
increases the total wealth of the world
so they made their money that's fine why
why are you so angry at them they're
giving you jobs they donate a lot to
charity they seem to do good work
it's because socialism is just an
ideology of envy Winston Churchill said
quote socialism is a philosophy of
failure the creed of ignorance and the
gospel of envy it's inherent virtue is
the equal sharing of misery if you're
looking at those billionaires and you're
all angry maybe you should look at
yourself and think how how can I become
a billionaire maybe I'd like to be a
billionaire - or at least a hundred
million here you know at least you know
shoot for the stars you'll land on the
moon what is that expression on it but
never made a lot of sense anyway
but that's what you got to look at look
at the envy it's it's envy is not a very
good quality from Samantha
mr. Knowles this is the question we've
all been waiting for what is your
favorite flavor of ice cream I don't
really care for ice cream I know that's
the least popular thing I've ever said I
don't care for it I never reach for it
it doesn't do a lot for me I have
sensitive teeth I've got to watch my
waistline no thank you
the one that I can't resist is a
chocolate malted milkshake that is
actually my favorite dessert that is the
one that I will always go for but ice
cream out of a container no thank you if
I have to Coffee is fine but doesn't do
a lot for me from Nicholas to the
Catholic cigar smoker of the daily wire
I like cigars you offer me ice cream or
a cigar I'll go for this cigar to the
Catholic Oh to the Catholic cigar smoker
of the daily wire as a cigar and pipe
smoker I would like to know what you
were smoking in the election special
also why do conservative smoke cigars
and pipes significantly more than anyone
else for a third question have you
considered pipe smoking an excellent
question this was a little Easter egg in
the election special I was smoking a
cigar I won't say the specific brand
name of the cigar but it was a cigar
that was made exclusively for Canada and
the reason I did that is because I'm
still waiting for Lena Dunham and all of
the left wingers from the last election
who promised that they were going to
move to Canada to move to Canada and
they haven't done it so I smoked a cigar
made exclusively for Canada just to
celebrate and you're the first person to
ask maybe we'll all go to Canada and get
more because these kind of cigars can
basically only be bought when you go up
to Canada if you know what I'm talking
about a lot of contraband from south of
the border okay from Jacob
we got time for probably one or two more
howdy Michael what advice do you have
for us libertarians that are seeing that
the Republicans held controlled the
presidency Senate and House of
Representatives for a full two years
would still have not reformed welfare
balance the budget eliminated any
governmental departments or repealed
Obamacare sincerely Jake great point
it's really frustrating I've been
indicating for entitlement reform for a
very long time I think that's a very
important issue only way to get our debt
deficits under control and yet it hasn't
happened I'll point out that Ronald
Reagan never shrink the size of the
government he didn't shrink the budget
he hoped he would it was the real one
failure of the Reagan administration
President Trump does not appear to be
interested in shrinking the size of the
federal budget
maybe shrinking the rate of growth that
would be nice
he's cut down the budgets of cabinet
departments that's a great start he's
deregulated significantly he's reduced
the size of various aspects of the
federal government but has this reduced
overall spending no absolutely not
that's probably not going to happen I
hope that we can get some kind of
entitlement reform through now that
we've lost the house I think you can
kiss that goodbye this is too bad you
know
libertarians have a strange relationship
to this administration because he's
Trump is speaking in some ways like a
populist and a protectionist all things
that libertarians tend to oppose and yet
he's stated his ultimate goal is the
elimination of tariffs
it's the elimination of barriers to
trade which libertarians should like
libertarians are gonna get a lot out of
this administration but it's not
libertarian administration it will not
be a libertarian administration and even
administration's that seemed more
favorably inclined to that way like
Reagan's also didn't fulfill that
promise might just unfortunately be a
pipe dream in a modern democracy but we
can keep on hoping one more I don't care
if I don't have time I'm doing one more
Michael I am applying to medical school
and trying to keep very high grades but
I cannot stand listening to my professor
pass off her opinions as facts in a
general education class she claims that
Trump abides by the same nationalism as
Hitler and that patriotism is the
opposite of nationalism how do I
approach the debate without jeopardizing
my grade thanks love the show you want
my honest answer this doesn't sound
great keep your mouth shut
that's the answer I don't know what are
you what do you want out of this all I
know from your question is that you
really want to go to medical school if
you really want to go to medical school
and you think that this woman is going
to hurt your grades to end
prevent you in some way from going to
medical school then just keep your mouth
shut what is to be gained by opening
your mouth you might be able to change
the minds of some of your classmates but
you could do that outside of class - you
can just talk to them beyond the debate
club whatever do conservative activism
are you gonna change the professor's
mind sounds like she's a little far gone
for that so I don't know that that's
likely and if you want to change your
mind you could do it after you're out of
her class and she can't affect your
grades
I have never hid my views but I've or
rarely I guess suppose a couple couple
uh movies and plays that I've been in
I've been very quiet and sometimes
technically you have to be quiet
I've never hid my views when someone
asks me I've never lied about them and I
don't think you should lie about your
views either but you don't need to go
around parading them all the time if
it's going to seriously hinder your life
you've got to be innocent as a dove and
wise as a serpent and you should
maintain that you've got to be a little
bit the lion a little bit the Fox to use
Machiavelli's phrase you've got to be I
don't know any other animals that we can
use I don't know you need to be a
pelican and a swan I don't think that
means anything but you've got to have a
little four beats' yeah you know you've
got to have a little awareness and
astuteness when you go about these
things because it's a real minefield if
you want to go out there and be totally
blunt about your views go for it I've
frequently done that in my life but it
will cost you if you're willing to bear
that cost go for it but if not maybe be
a little astute and live to fight
another day okay that's our show if
you're at the University of Michigan
come on by tonight I can't wait to see
you if not I'm sure you can catch it on
the Internet at some point I'm sure
we'll have it up there someday in the
meantime have a good weekend I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
we'll see on Monday
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018